Supercharge your Pytorch training
loop with Hugging Face Accelerate.
There are multiple setups on which you can run
your training: it could be on CPU, GPUs, TPUs.
Distributed on one machine with several
devices, or several machines (often called
nodes) each with multiple devices. On top of that
there are new tweaks to make your training faster
or more memory efficient, like mixed precision
and DeepSpeed. Each of those setups or training
tweaks, requires you to change the code of
your training loop in one way or another
and to learn a new API. All those setups are
handled by the Trainer API, and there are several
third-party libraries that can also help you with
that. The problem with those is that they can feel
like a black box and that it might not be easy to
implement the tweak to the training loop you need.
Accelerate has been designed specifically to let
you retain full control over your training loop
and be as non-intrusive as possible. With
just four lines to add to your training loop
(here shown on the code of the training
loop from the "Raw training loop" video),
Accelerate will handle all the setups and
training tweaks mentioned on the first slide.
It's only one API to learn and
master instead of ten different ones.
More specifically, you have to import
and instantiate an accelerator object,
that will handle all the necessary
code for your specific setup.
Then you have to send it the model, optimizer and
dataloaders you are using in the prepare method,
which is the main method to remember. Accelerate
handles device placement, so you don't need to put
your batch on the specific device you are using.
Finally, you have to replace the loss.backward
line by accelerate.backward(loss),
and that's all you need!
Accelerate also handles distributed evaluation.
You can still use a classic evaluation loop
such as the one we saw in the "Raw training
loop" video, in which case all processes
will each perform the full evaluation.
To use a distributed evaluation, you just
have to adapt your evaluation loop like this:
pass along the evaluation dataloader
to the accelerator.prepare method,
like for training. Then you can dismiss the
line that places the batch on the proper device,
and just before passing your
predictions and labels to your metric,
use accelerator.gather to gather together
the predictions and labels from each process.
A distributed training script has to be launched
several times on different processes (for instance
one per GPU you are using). You can use the
PyTorch tools if you are familiar with them,
but Accelerate also provides an
easy API to configure your setup
and launch your training script. In a terminal,
run accelerate config and answer the small
questionnaire to generate a configuration
file with all the relevant information,
then you can just run accelerate launch,
followed by the path to your training script.
In a notebook, you can use the notebook_launcher
function to launch your training function.